好 大家今天想非常快速地分享一下。
我说我们这台LiCa D-Lux 8。
因为它的电子使用说明。
小白能快速上手的一些设置。
以及资讯对比一下富士的LiCa以及礼光。
因为我觉得这三台相机有点相似之处。
可是我看到那么有什么人发对比。
真的希望我能早点刷到。
所以我今天会自己来做一天。
我们赶紧开始
首先开机机用这一点我觉得很喜欢。
因为这样你就不用怕把镜头盖弄丢了。
有配套闪光灯这一点。
也非常契合我拍人上的习惯。
而且这个闪光灯是不用单独充电的。
好喜欢
不会很重
不用的时候你就可以直接关掉。
以及通过调整波轮来控制胶段的设计。
就比这些更直观更方便。
当你快速地感受到。
当下的场景更适合怎么样的胶段。
以及我特别惊喜的是它的触摸屏真的很灵敏。
不管是点对焦 滑动 放大街都很丝滑。
整台相机操作也是非常简单好上手的。
这边是快门速度
新手直接调了A档就好了。
右边这里是曝光补偿。
然后轻按的话可以调节iOS。
屏幕上还有两个功能键。
这个是取景器
可以根据自己的拍摄习惯来设置。
功能键2可以直接切换照片和视频模式。
这一点我觉得非常适合想要双摄的朋友。
边走边拍照 边拍视频真的很方便。
特别要提的是这一点。
在富士以及李光上面是没有的加分。
然后Menu键是可以单独设置照片和视频参数的。
如果你是新手的话就可以选这个AF自动对焦。
C式连续多次对焦。
如果你在拍摄的时候有东西这样动来动去。
就等于相机可以快速智能的帮你识别。
如果是想用它拍人像比较多的话。
就可以在这里开启人眼识别。
那我是套了VV绿镜拍的。
但是我觉得离我想像的来看会差一点点。
就可以在JPG这里调整对比度和饱喝度。
会有一些微妙的差别。
但是又不像直接刷一层绿镜那种感觉。
以及我觉得拍摄时候降低一点曝光补偿。
这样拍出来会比较得味。
如果你非常喜欢来卡位。
也有刚好有一万出头预算呢？
我其实不太推荐它。
说我觉得没有完美的相机。
但是有一些相机它是一个优点。
可以让你接受它的其他缺点。
我觉得如果大家想要入手这台相机的话。
可以先听听看它的缺点。
你可不可以接受吧？
首先就是这台相机它不支持来卡绿镜。
就只能用机内这几个绿镜。
虽然说开摔也没有说不好吧？
但是就有一种被砍力当的感觉。
没关系 我后期AI调了一下。
难不倒我
但是我觉得很想请我。
为什么你对高拍摄是这样的呀？
我帮助这台机型的问题。
还是我这台相机的问题。
但你拍20张左右呢？
就开始有点对不上焦了。
以及比起这两个点来说。
我更加难以接受的是。
它的屏幕拍出来是很像一个监控。
暗光拍摄下更是像直接监控上面截下来的。
虽然说它拍出来是很清晰的。
然后光影也很棒
我很喜欢
但是你拍的时候看了那个屏幕。
真的有一种在当侦查。
然后抓小偷的感觉。
就是拍照的体验不太妙了。
以及第四点我特别不能接受的就是。
你不说 我不说
你看得出哪让是手机拍。
哪让是相机拍的吗？
如果不是看文件名。
我真的想不出它转是相机拍的。
那我以前是觉得一万多的手机。
跟一万多的相机拍出来。
是有很大的区别的。
但是我第一次在这台相机上。
感受到这个边界非常模糊。
说到这个价格呢？
我就特别想对付一下。
就是X100系列。
LiCa D-Lux以及李光GR3。
我知道他们对比来说有点怪怪的。
但我觉得他们的价格 机身体积。
不可更换镜头的点。
以及他们风格化的绿镜这些点。
真的很像一样
以及我每次用这台相机拍照。
基本都是跟那几个朋友一起。
所以我会更量从上手难度。
然后使用体验
以及色彩耐看度是三个角度。
去对比分享
不过李光相机在我的手里。
如果大家想看详细点分享。
可以转播我的另外一瓶笔记。
我们现在就隔空开始吧？
从机身来说
我觉得真正能做到口袋机的。
只有李光GR3
他在拍摄的时候给你的轻松。
真的是非常非常美妙的体验。
我感觉有了他
就真的变得超级喜欢拍照。
什么都想拍一下的感觉。
机身辨识才是第二才是LiCa。
然后第三才是富士差100系列。
然后第二就是他们的色彩。
都是非常让人着迷的色彩。
属于各有各的特色。
但我个人是都非常非常喜欢的。
但是如果你要长期主力来看的话呢？
我就有点想要鸡蛋里头补同一下了。
因为我这绿镜看着有机能回忆你。
首先就是我觉得这三项镜都非常的吃光线。
相对来说我觉得富士的绿镜最容易拍你。
虽然说他现在有出新的绿镜。
然后你也可以从机内去调参数。
但是拍出来普遍涂抹感都会比较重。
尤其是如果你要后期调色的话呢？
他其实是没有那么包容的。
那李光的副片模式我觉得也是同理。
但他的正片模式呢？
是那种非常符合肉眼。
但是有一点微妙的任务系无声的。
回忆的加分的感觉的色彩。
我这个人真的非常喜欢。
然后就是莱卡
虽然说我前面有吐槽。
我觉得莱卡略近太自然。
看上去他自古保底。
但反而他的惊喜是最多的。
以及他拍出来的光影层次我真的真的很喜欢。
可以对比一下跟富士拍的。
那色彩耐看度在我个人的排名是这样子的。
大家可以参考一下啊？
但有些相机呢？
他的一个优点
就可以让你自己去适应他的其他缺点。
所以我觉得大家在选相机的时候呢？
要看看自己在拍摄过程中最看重什么？
以及我们这些主管测评说出来的缺点。
你能不能接受
总结
我还是非常非常喜欢他。
但我想说他绝对不是一台保底的相机。
他更适合你有其他设备的情况下。
把它作为备用机
就像这件熟的
他真的很像开盲合优。
拍着拍着就会给你一些很惊喜的照片。
那想用他来当主力机的话。
可能是有点神哦
一万出头可以让你体验得细莱卡风味。
不知道你觉得值不值呢？
说外外有什么问题欢迎问我哦。
我们下期再见拜拜。